yes
guys I bask and your love for me
happy Wednesday everyone and even you
illegal migrants Belize Miracles
I believe that's also happy Wednesday
according to my high school Spanish
which I failed all right so like a woman
trying to throw a football
the immigration crisis is spiraling out
of control
laughs
it's just terrible
why do we even say these things you
don't need us to tell you that although
Fox News is the only one that does if
Bill malusion and his gorgeous head of
hair spend one more day on the southern
border he gets a free milkshake and a
blowout
he could donate his hair to Bald lions
and why doesn't he
the border is a mess no doubt but now so
is the sanctuary that is New York City
up until recently migrants were being
housed in an upscale hotel in Midtown
Manhattan it's got a rooftop pool a nice
bar fine furnishings you know things
Jamie lissow will never have
ever
the city had plans to move the single
illegal males from the hotel to a
facility facility in Brooklyn to make
room for migrant families but the men
are not budging
so how's that for irony we say to the
male migrants Welcome to our country and
then they turn around and say to
incoming migrant families go back to you
where you came from
so it appears that illegal immigrants
are also vehemently against illegal
immigration
the moment they get here they turn from
helpless Refugee into Ann Coulter
I'm surprised they didn't start chanting
build a wall build a wall
my goodness this is amazing so when
buses showed up to haul the men away
from the hotel to a simpler but clean
facility they didn't hop on instead they
took to the sidewalk out front camped
out demanding they stay and pulling the
Asylum Seeker card they claim they're
refugees but complained the
accommodations at the Brooklyn Cruise
terminal are subpar
then they give the shaft to incoming
families
here's one migrant's hot take for all
men it's only four bathrooms if one gets
sick everyone gets sick it's very ugly
the beds are horrible
they're a piece of fabric they're like a
military bed now
oh sounds like your house Jamie
all men and this coming from guys who
can fit 40 into a Toyota Corolla when
sneaking across the border
I get it though for bathrooms that means
they're a taco night away from disaster
I give these Asylum Seekers something
like a military bed you mean a bed
comfortable enough for our troops who
need to get a good night's sleep before
going to war next time maybe give us a
heads up on the thread count you'd
prefer you know when you sneak into our
country you freeloaders I'm sorry but
what Asylum Seeker would turn down any
of this unless they're lying about the
so-called hardships that they're
allegedly escaping from I mean where are
they seeking Asylum from the Sandals
Resort in Cabo
have you seen some of these alleged
refugees they're dressed better than U.S
citizens where do coyotes drop them off
the Nike outlet store
they don't look tired and downtrodden to
me you know this looks downtrodden
[Laughter]
I don't see that
see the scene people look more exhausted
after spending two weeks on a Carnival
Cruise Line
they're not the refugees like the ones
who came through Ellis Island and if
they were refugees ask those single men
why they left their families behind it's
like a reverse Titanic where Jack pushes
Rose off the Driftwood
that's how I would have ended it
I think we're being played thankfully
one smart sexy man is pointing all this
out
I'm beginning to think that their
hardship was greatly exaggerated they're
coming here not because uh they're you
know refugees uh uh in danger from
climate or crime or poverty it's
incentivized by our country to come here
for jobs and free stuff because what
desperate Refugee comes to a sanctuary
and complains about room and board
so true that guy's so hot he should come
with a warning like a McDonald's apple
pie does
so if you're fleeing Central America it
had nothing to do with root causes
unless the root cause is American
generosity so you can stop pretending to
look Kamala
and sorry you can't call yourself
refugees and still demand a timeshare
when you get here the fact is it's Lefty
activists who are filling the heads of
migrants with more
than an episode of Yellowstone
has a New York Post points out activists
are deeply involved in the standoff
itself with the larger effort to ramp up
illegal migration
so this whole Refugee crisis was a lie I
mean it's a crisis for us but not for
them and I say that for you know being
very very pro-immigration with
adjustments based on what our country
needs but we're not allowed to question
any of this or say hey I wonder if a 300
a night room might be crazy
you remember those pictures of another
hotel with trashed rooms and empty beer
bottles food thrown out I mean these
guys are partying and they're partying
on cat's dime you know
assuming she pays taxes
and now they're biting the hand that's
feeding them for free sorry folks the
next time you hear the word Refugee
think of that great Tom Petty song and
not these ingrates at the Watson Hotel
[Applause]
her last name is McDonald but she
doesn't have a farm most of the evening
added on Fox Business
foreign
does this man write the news he delivers
it on his paper route Fox News
contributor in Washington Times opinion
editor Charlie Herr
[Applause]
if he has to hear one more Alaska joke
he's going to get up and leave on his
dog sled
actor writer and comedian Jamie lissow
and she's living paycheck to paycheck
mainly because she keeps stealing her
neighbor's paychecks Fox News
contributor Kat too
[Applause]
Jamie I think that it's taxpayers here
in New York City we're all a little
upset watching people get 300 a night
hotel rooms and then complain that's
coming directly from people like me but
it's really got to upset you seeing
immigrants illegal immigrants living a
far better life than you I mean like
they're having a great time they're
socializing they have friends some of
them are actually making out yeah some
of them some of them are allowed near
girls like what
um
you really just when you're describing I
was like oh you're like rooftop pool I
never I don't even have a floor top pool
um you know much more expensive it is to
get it up there and um
it's really frustrating and that's like
a i i this whole story blew my mind
especially the thing about them sending
other families away yes right and right
near there there's much more affordable
housing by the way like just a little
bit I've stayed it's not like the best
area but I stayed in a hotel a couple
blocks from there last time I was here
not a great area I remember went to the
front desk and I go Hey where's the
men's room and she goes just anywhere
outside
[Laughter]
um
can I do really quick I have one point
yes and one joke unless nobody laughs
and then I have two points
um
yes please let's be I think we have to
be grateful right like the they come
they're seeking Asylum and wherever
they're coming from we're trying to help
and we're trying to do the best we can
and I think there's like a little bit of
like be really grateful we're trying to
like provide the best we can whoever's
in charge it's trying to buy like the
best food and and do the best they can
so it's like just I don't know maybe try
to don't complain about everything and
go wow that's really kind that people
did like for instance when I was married
I probably slept
um half of the years I slept on the
couch right but I was like at least I'm
inside the house yeah do you know what I
mean that's like a good place to be
that's what they should do I was on the
couch so much like when my kids wanted
to watch they'd be like Dad do you mind
if we sit on your cry bed and watch a
movie
that was a point and a sad very sad
story
oh man um Charlie I have to ask you or
this when it when it dawned on me that
the male illegal immigrants were telling
they didn't want to move to the families
they are definitely going to be
Republicans yeah
the Democrats are counting on on all of
these uh sexual Americans to become who
Democrats go no they get the moment
they're here they're saying Get out of
here
get off my lawn get off my lawn
no it's it's real simple it's all human
nature which is what's unique about our
country is that we have a country that's
built on understanding human nature and
sort of working around it but it's just
basically of course they don't want new
people coming in and taking their stuff
any more than anybody else does the
whole country doesn't want it but it is
true the whole thing not not that the
crisis isn't real the crisis is real but
it is an entirely manufactured one
manufactured by politicians it's
entirely a scam and all of these people
are pawns and when and when Democrats
criticize Republican Governors for using
migrants as punts no they're not you're
using them as pawns and you've been
using them as pawns to to in order to
build up this insane charade about
racism in America
um they are the ones who are actually
abusing these you may be you know I
drifted off I was thinking about it like
a New Yorker cartoon I should submit
it's like a lifetime chess board yeah
and you know people play them and the
pond goes stop using me as a pawn
that was really good I swear to God when
he was saying that I was like why does
nobody ever use someone as a rook yes
I've used someone as a queen before
Liz yes Liz I wanted to ask this
question for maybe two years but I
didn't have the guts to do it so you
give it to me no yes no but but I
mentioned it yesterday on the five and
then today that like I kept looking at
the migrants and I go like they didn't
look like they walked very far so I
never know where the drop-off point is
where they just all of a sudden and then
they always had a white bag they always
had a white bag stuff and they were all
they weren't sweating like when I think
of somebody a refugee they're sweating
they're on a Lifeboat they're like
coming from Cuba they're coming they're
fleeing Nazi Germany they're they're
fleeing Chairman Mao they're fleeing the
Potato Famine Jamie
but here it's like it's like they're all
they're all like hell they're healthy
some are actually a little plump list
well
they do look plump I know you know you
think women and children fleeing missile
strikes or something but they these are
men men in designer bubble jackets yes
throwing away dozens of bags of what
looks to me like Chick-fil-A I'm like
bring it over here exactly so you know
what gets me is that this looks like a
block party for activists there are more
activists showing up at these hotels and
the migrants inside so it feels like all
right if if you care about it by the way
they're not prophets existing on the
taxpayers nickel you take them in yeah
you take in the illegal immigrants right
when I saw those dozens of bags just
tossed out right yeah what was it
hamburgers I mean it looked like I
couldn't tell it looked like peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches and don't
knock a peanut good people I will never
knock that don't you Liz I promise
you'll be off this show in a hot minute
cat migrants were actually delaying your
path to work today weren't they yes what
tell us about it please well I know
we're talking about this as like an
immigration crisis and it proves the
immigration crisis out of control for me
the thing I notice about this most is it
proves how insane the welfare state is
right okay this is a welfare issue first
and foremost because like you said
Charlie like if you're in a luxury hotel
room for free and being like get out of
here for to be like I don't wanna is
like not the craziest thing I've ever
heard the craziest thing I've ever heard
is that our government has such a level
of disrespect for our money that they're
like what do we do ah let's just put
them in luxury hotels exactly everybody
will pay for it they don't care even
though they still stay here even though
they we all just endured the the Dismal
Christmas tree traffic yes and we
somehow still didn't move out I I mean
and also for these activists to be
getting out there and making such a big
deal about the right to a luxury hotel
room I think it diminishes the real
struggles exactly that a lot of people
who really are fleeing aside you know
fleeing for a Asylum face and people
that want to come here legally and get a
work visa just how bogged down and
expensive and ridiculous that process is
focus on those things the the right to a
luxury hotel room is not what any real
struggling person is so pissed off about
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else